- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is expect the unexpected.
Over to you, George Soros.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- George, you've written,
"The second world war gave me a lesson
"that I've never forgotten."
What was the lesson?
- The main lesson that I learned
during the war is
to expect the unexpected
The situations that you get into
are so out of context with
what you have grown up with
that you have to examine
the framework in which you think
and then you realize
that we all work with preconceived ideas
and those ideas don't necessarily
correspond to reality.
So there is this gap between
perception and reality
and that's the gap that I
have really kind of explored
and also exploited.
- [Narrator] After the war,
Soros left Hungary and went to England
to the London School of Economics.
- So I think we all grew
up with a set of beliefs
that came from our parents,
our family, our friends, our surroundings
and a lot of those help us
but a lot of them limit us as well.
And so unless you want to live a life
that's exactly like the people around you
then you need to start to question things,
question some of the beliefs
that you grew up with
and understand are these
actually representative
of what you're about or not.
This is why actually finding the one word
is really important,
having the self-awareness to know
what it is that you stand for,
what the most important
thing is in your life
and then building around that,
both a business and a life
that now has purpose and meaning
instead of accidentally having things
randomly happening to you that help you.
Now we're setting out
to create a more powerful course forward,
having that self-awareness really helps.
Let's look at your beliefs around money.
I don't think many people
grew up with a healthy
belief around money.
Some people believe money is everything,
all that matters is money
and some people believe that
money is the root of all evil.
Right?
Money is negative
and you shouldn't do it.
And anybody who goes for money is greedy.
If you grew up believing
that money is evil
and it's greedy to ask for money
then you never charge what you're worth.
If you're an entrepreneur,
one of the things that we
are terrible at in general
is charging what we're worth.
Most entrepreneurs should
be increasing their prices
by at least 30%
based on the value they're
actually providing.
We undersell ourselves
and often that comes from
a belief around money.
Or if you want to go
and have the impact that you want to have,
you want to be able to build a team,
you want to be able to
help your community.
You want to give back to causes,
you want to build a real business
you might have to charge more.
But you'll never do it
until you fix your belief around money.
And so understanding
what your beliefs are,
understanding the person
that you actually want to be,
understanding what your one word is
and then seeing the limiting
beliefs that you have
and the positive ones that you want to use
to reinforce and build yourself up
make a huge difference.
This is your blueprint and
until you recognize it,
until you audit it,
until you examine it,
you're going to continue
running the same patterns
over and over and over
and over and over again.
No matter what strategy
somebody gives you,
you're never going to
really follow through on it
because the blueprint that you're running
is holding you back.
That's why for a lot of these things,
the strategy itself doesn't really matter,
like how to go out and do
this doesn't really matter
because if you're not ready for it,
if you're still holding yourself
back with the same story
that you've been telling
yourself your whole life,
those sets of limiting beliefs
will continue to hold you back
until you break through them
and then you'll be ready
to hear the strategy and
tactics to move forward.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what's the
biggest limiting belief
that you have, that you have recognized
and are trying to break through
or have recently broken through on?
Leave it down the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Joe Dodani.
Joe, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
it really means a lot to me, Joe.
I hope you're enjoying the read
and that it's brought value to
your business and your life.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I hope you have an amazing day.
I believe in you
and hope you continue
to believe in yourself
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going